[Music]
each time i awake
this planet seems somehow different
where are we
you see things others can't
this is the power that flows through
this land
yet you do not fully understand it
but whatever comes i will be ready
okay let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
you all know the target shiva's dominant
and only the dominant how do we even
know the girl will be among them
our kind do not question orders we
follow them
sergeant let's summon their icon
i can't i think's a bloody mountain
our foe will not relinquish their mother
crystal easily
this will be a bitter fight
you should not be out of doors we have
discussed this
come joshua your father will be
expecting us
[Music]
i am joshua's shield
[Music]
i'm sworn to protect him
what do you mean you refuse did you not
pledge your swords to our cause
what does it matter it was the dull
necks who drove back the crusaders in
the battle of the twin realms was it
without the blessing of the mother
crystal we cannot defend our realm from
the spread of the blight
imperial vipers do they really mean to
invade us
[Music]
but that's impossible
the legacy of the crystals
has shaped our history
so long enough
[Music]
i'll kill you
if it's the last thing i do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's too cold to change out here
dang i'm late for mom's rally
[Music]
subway card check you got the house key
yeah i got it
come on we're going to be late
hey dude i am so filling your suit with
snow
are you still wearing your suit yeah you
know just in case
it's gonna be fine
see this is my favorite part of living
in harlem
pop-up street fair best food in the city
awesome music
man this would be great for the last
speed i was working on
i should get back into mixing yeah it's
been a while
now what do you think about rio morales
you gonna vote for her
it's still hard to think of mom as a
politician she's been a teacher my whole
life
similar skill sets right growling people
educating them
making sure they don't throw things at
each other
hi i'm brian horton creative director at
insomniac games
we're excited to show you this first
look at gameplay from marvel spider-man
miles morales
our story picks up one year after the
events of the first game
and we find miles new home harlem is in
danger
trouble brews while miles mom rio
morales leads an election rally
a war between the devious energy
corporation roxanne and the underground
a high-tech criminal army led by the
tinkerer starts to break out
in this gameplay sequence captured on
playstation 5 hardware
the underground attacks roxane sending
the rally into chaos in a fight that
spills onto the brake weight bridge
where the underground tries to steal
roxanne's experimental energy source
new form let's take a look
let's not shoot each other all right
we're after the new form ignore
everything else
get rid of him then grab as much as you
can carry
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
i have to stop this
people are trapped over there i have to
push past these guys
where is he
kill you
[Music]
no
no no no no no
everybody get out
thank you man
i've got an idea
i need something they can cross
i can stop this
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
magic both beautiful and powerful
binds together our long history
that common bond we share is the legacy
of hogwarts
[Music]
now it is time to add your own story to
these hallowed walls
and quite possibly shape the future
of the wizarding world
every corridor every portrait
every stone in this castle tells the
story
witches and wizards who came before
here you will meet lifelong friends and
grow into your own
magical abilities in the classrooms of
the world's
most talented professors
and while your journey begins at holes
brewing potions taming fantastic beasts
and mastery spells
there is a larger world beyond these
walls
a world filled with dangers you can't
yet
imagine an ancient knowledge
long gone from this world
that strange and mysterious talent you
possess
may be the key to unlocking this dormant
power
your potential
is limitless
but what form will it take
the journey ahead will reveal
what you stand for
[Music]
the choices you make now
will define the legacy of hogwarts
[Music]
hi everyone i'm dan vondrag creative
director at raven
one of our goals as developers is to
bring the game world to life unlike
anything you've ever experienced and the
playstation 5
is making that happen with the power of
the new console we've been able to
significantly enhance the overall
experience
from what you see in the world how it
feels in your hands to what you hear
around you
in black ops cold war you will be
transported to the year 1981
in the middle of one of the most
dangerous times the world has ever known
the height of the cold war the following
is a portion of the first campaign
mission
where you've been given the name of a
high value target linked to the iran
hostage crisis
but in true black ops style nothing is
as it seems
take a look
kasim is out of the picture how long
before we get
a rash the team arrived in turkey a few
hours ago
they should be in position shortly
airfield's just up ahead let's go find
this [ __ ]
priority is to ideal raj things go hot
nice check it out
incoming truck left side
arrash might be in the truck
i can't make out his face yet i don't
the want he just diced everyone in a
truck
that's got to be a rash hold fire we
need a positive id
that's our man take him out
[Music]
[Music]
we're not done yet
here
takes off
this one's part of the plan let's go
we hope you enjoyed that sneak peek at
the campaign for black ops cold war
there are many more twists and turns
along the way as you begin to unravel
the truth and we can't wait for you to
play it soon
in addition to the story campaign cold
war features the next generation of
multiplayer online combat
and an all new awesome zombies
experience today i have the special
honor to announce on behalf of my
friends at treyarch
that the playstation community doesn't
have to wait to play multiplayer
starting this friday playstation players
will be able to play the multiplayer
alpha exclusively
on playstation 4. and for those of you
that are watching at home on your ps4
you can pre-load the experience starting
tomorrow we can't wait to see you online
friday and through the weekend
enjoy the rest of the show
[Music]
chris what the hell
take him away
in life and in death we give
glory the bell
tolls for us all they're coming
[Laughter]
again
[Music]
quit being so paranoid
long ago a young girl went with her
mother to pick berries for her father
who was hard at work but the forest
greeted them with a dark
cold silence the bushes empty
yet determined to find the berries the
rascal broke free of mother's grasp
and vanished into the trees
[Music]
mothers worried cries faded fast as the
girl ran on
over vine under branch
and into the forest
[Applause]
it's just a local tale
[Music]
if it's just looking window shop away
[Music]
you want out of a time loop you gotta
learn how it works
black reef is a puzzle and each
visionary is a different piece
here's eagle i am a respected scientist
i've done so many loops i've learned to
run circles around him
hey over here i'm coming for you
i've tried taking my targets out one by
one
more than i can remember but there is
never enough time
i go after one another lives because
right now half an island away a
different visionary is throwing his
knightly cannibal masquerade
alexis dorsey everybody shut up
this is my jam igor is a big fan
yet somehow he never makes it to the
party
something keeps him home gold are you
there buddy
here's the invite to the party and
here's why igor blew it off
he made some kind of scientific
breakthrough that morning
i did it i did it it works daddy makes
every move
unless i get there first
no experiment no breakthrough
no reason for igor not to drink his
disappointment with alexis
now i got a shot at killing them both at
the same time
oh i'm talking about you baby
a little house here
eight targets on my list every one of
them with grand plans for
eternal life to break the loop i gotta
break the rules
clocks ticking
and you just ran out of time you keep
forgetting cult
i'm not like those other idiots
only got one name on my list yours
[Music]
[Music]
that day if our positions were switched
would our fates be different
would i have your life and your mind
you a demon
[Music]
real before me
[Music]
this is
rest in peace
[Music]
[Applause]
devil may cry
[Music]
[Music]
what are they doing did those fugitive
morons
burn down their own hideout it sounds
idiotic
but that's exactly what it looks like
bad guama for burning down my farm
hi i'm lorne lanning creative director
of odd world soulstorm
and we're excited to bring you an
all-new exclusive trailer from the game
here our unlikely hero abe finds himself
fresh off the back of freeing his people
from the nefarious rupture farms he
thinks the journey is over
but soon discovers it has only just
begun
the stakes are higher the threats are
larger the obstacles are more devious
and it's all made possible by the power
of playstation 5.
enjoy
we are not letting that egg guy get away
from
us again
[Music]
wait here hey why not hold up i could go
for a sandwich right now we got to get
out of here come on
let's get out of here my tummy's
growling
[Music]
gregory your friends are worried about
you
they're here with me please come out
gregory i may have lost my tempo earlier
but it was just a quench it won't happen
again
it's been such a difficult day for all
of us
why don't you come out and we can play a
game together
it won't happen again
gregory be still
i think she's found us
[Music]
[Music]
soul of the lost withdrawn from its
vessel
that strength be granted so the world
might be mended
soul of the lost withdrawn from its
vessel
let strength be granted so the world
might be mended
so the world might be mended
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
i shall await thy return slayer of
demons
[Music]
welcome to welcome to welcome to the
future
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
can you kill something that big
we want you
my name is marcus my name is cara my
name is connor
[Music]
after all we've been
it's time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so now you know thank you all for
joining us today
and for being part of this amazing
journey
it's your passion as fans of gaming that
drives us to deliver a truly new
generation of experiences on ps5
from everyone at playstation we
appreciate your continued support
and we look forward to you getting your
hands on ps5
very soon to close
let me leave you with one more quick
look
the time draws near
smaller
you must prepare yourself
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
i'm fearless
[Music]
i'm fearless
hey
i'm fearless
playstation
you